well hello everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast normal behavior of
rodents understand it then respect it I
am Marcel porridge in teal and I will be
your moderator for today's event we have
a few important announcements to make
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive so we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon and the
lower right-hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems Veon or here in this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window also made a your
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
marina snip Kowski dr. marina sniffs
Kowski has DPN has a master's of science
and a PhD and her academic background
encompasses doctor and veterinary
medicine who graduated with honors from
the veterinary school the Buenos Aires
University in 2004 her field or fields
of expertise are in clinical pathology
animal behavior and neuro sciences
laboratory animal scientists
biostatistics and experimental design
she's a diplomat and diplomat in canine
and feline internal medicine from the
Las Americas University in 2009 she's
also a bittleman
and clinical authority from the Latin
American Veterinary ethology College in
2012
and she has a specialization is the
statistics for Health Sciences science
sciences school Buenos Aires University
in 2004 she has a master's in inside
corner oh and you know in the chronology
from the
Laura University which she obtained in
2012 she she some master students in
laboratory animal science and welfare at
the Barcelona University in Spain oh she
will be in from 2015 to 2018 and she has
a PhD in neuroscience veterinary school
Buenos Aires University 2013 as you can
see marina is very very well qualified
for this presentation her current
position
she's at the IBC and laboratory animal
facility manager in coordination and
supervision of the animal health and
welfare medicine school bueno scientist
she has been in the position since March
2012 her professional she membership of
the career for research support of
National Research Council kinesin at
institute of cell and molecular biology
medicine school Buenos Aires University
she's an icon member at the veterinary
school Research Institute at there
Salvador University she has been a
member of the I cook since 2013 she's a
board member of their gen Tinian
association of laboratory animal science
and technology and she's a pro
Secretariat since March 2014 she is a
head professor of biostatistics and
veterinary school El Salvador University
since August 2008 I will now turn it
over to marina Snell Kowski for her
presentation so marina
well thank you myself for that very kind
introduction and good morning to
everyone I would like to thank you for
being there for choosing this lecture
and to thank the organizers of this
event for inviting me along so I would
like to apologize for my cue poor years
of English since as you know I'm from
Argentina so this is not my mother
tongue but I'll just do my best
I think we'll manage so let's talk about
behavior we can define behavior as an
individual response an animal responds
to stimuli whether the stimulus is
internal for instance a change in a
hormone level or an external stimulus
such as a change of variation in their
environment so the main function of
behavior is to allow the animal to adapt
to those variations environment and also
for our benefit behavioral response is
at say enviable I mean something we can
see or we can even measure so that the
response will be reporting us about an
internal processing something very
complex that is happening inside the
animal and as we cannot see it or touch
it or measure it we can infer about it
with the salient viable that is the
behavioral response so this internal
processing could be a physiological
State for instance estrus in a female
whether we can also infer about
pathological States such as sickness
behavior or even emotional states to
instance fear we can infer that an
animal is fearful with its behavior also
we can know what motivational state the
animal song by seeing its behavior for
instance our hunger or sexual arousal
also this behavior response can allow us
to assess the well-being of that animal
always with objective measurements of
these behaviors and we can assess also
they are the patient of abilities of
that animal observing its behavior and
its behavior response to change in the
environment but I really wonder if we
would know their normal behavior
patterns of the animals we work with of
the animal species we are used to work
with in order to know they are not on
all behavior patterns we should know
first that natural history of that
species that is um which are its
ancestors its wild ancestors and what
evolution and amplification are made and
provoked changes not only in their
features their external antenna typical
features but also in their behavior that
if a process we can call you know rodent
a process of laboratory station that
would be domestication of laboratory
animals so we should know the behavior
phylogeny an antigenic and of course
which captivity in these variations were
across the time of evolution so if you
know sorry if we know how their normal
behavior it we are capable of assessing
if there is an altered behavior which
could be due to a physical illness or
even to emotional distress such as
transportation any kind of experimental
procedure or even a social conflict so
if we know how the normal behavior is
and we can recognize outer behavior we
will be able to respect and to ensure
animal welfare knowing that one of the
freedoms
we usually try to respect by ensuring
animal welfare is the freedom to express
more normal behavior of course in order
to respect it we first need to know it
so actually the behavior of a patroller
of rodents it's very complex I'll just
choose in this tab to speak about some
of the patterns that I think are most
important for the animal facility
manager course all departments are
important but we are going to discuss
social agonistic territorial exploratory
sexual and maternal behaviors today but
first we should review what our or how
our sensory systems in rodents because
of course they are very related to the
expression of normal behaviors so smell
of affection is obviously the best
developed sense and is required for food
finding for territorial recognition for
updaters and social kills but also they
them sense of smell provides a very
important exchange of information system
whether it's um the situation viewing
physics and even scent glands aggression
there are a few compounds that are very
important for this communication the
smell and that are for instance matron
United moorings
unfirm we are going to talk a lot about
pheromones today without side actually
sight is the most important times in
rodents as you may know their vision is
diplomatic that if they are blind to red
color but they can see ultraviolet also
they have a very poor poor visual
marketing especially in albino strains
it is worse little worse but they can
see a high contrast fear about hearing
what you may know that they have a
broader spectrum compared to human and
they can both live in an ultrasonic song
so of course we are deaf to that and in
it in order to hear it or Automator it
we need a special apparatus this
ultrasonic Sandling is used for other
pop calling for sexual calling and also
warning about potatoes or page intruders
and proud touch they have a very special
ID here
tactile hair are called the brain that
is connected with a very specialized
region in the brain cortex in order to
integrate that information but what
happens with their sensory systems in
captivity in our animal facility
conditions actually we usually use a
very bright light which is not the best
for their sense of sight it would be
better to use a red light when it's
possible or a yellow light or a melty
light that is less right same thing or
similar happens with environmental
sounds actually sometimes there they are
exposed to electronic devices and other
treatment sounds that maybe they have
they emit an ultrasonic sound of course
we don't know because man we cannot hear
it
what about smell in our daily daily
basis a bad change depending change we
remove the odors it makes disappear
their scent marking disappeared so it
might it doesn't always but it might
create
sort of social problems between kite
cage mates so the idea would be to renew
only let's say a 90% of the bedding and
leave 10% remaining of the old bedding
that has those special cells some and
others are very important for them to
mark their territory and their social
relationships and about social behavior
actually social behavior should we
should say that it's the most important
behavior we should say in world Antonina
prey animal there are different social
aggregation patterns a species could be
strictly with areas it would be solitary
or it could be social or some social or
facultative Oteri's it depends on their
resources and of course it depends on
the species
it's a typical suspicious so in order to
have a social behavior they need to
communicate with each other
I thought as we said communication can
be visual through gestures and body
postures tactile so touching each other
or passing against each other or
huddling and of course is very important
there attractive and
Semyon chemical communication that is
the pheromonal communication and the
organizations that that as we said they
could be audible or ultrasonic there are
different social behavior patterns for
instance social attention that is to
detect and to go towards conspiracy
social investigation smell theme
vocalist aiding and agonistic behavior
that will discuss further on of course
for the social behavior to agree
it has to be organized so my species has
its own social organization and
hierarchy and we will discuss it as well
so the species that are strictly various
for instance but guinea pigs and gerbils
they need under math aggregate they have
an inner drive to abrogate to link
together of course there's some social
life provides the directions provides
easiness to find food so there's a
hierarchy there's a social organization
that is usually called colony and it's a
higher life organization the hierarchy
starts with the dominant nail that is
usually the biggest and a habit one he
dominates over food over space control
and of course of verb attraction usually
in a colony only the dominant male is
able to properties to mate and of course
this dominance it's shown with dominance
postures with fighting with barbering
that is more typical in in mind so
continuing with the hierarchy comes to
reproductive female group that they have
their own hierarchy among female and
they usually wait out the parts together
we will talk about it later with
maternal behavior then the subordinate
males and then the young and the
juvenile but what about mine actually
mine should be considered as facultative
food areas species because they cannot
link together and the
what they would update or not depending
on resources and of course depending on
the opponent specific attraction is the
internal factor that makes them to live
together actually my social order is yet
poorly understood it is supposed to be
despot knows then I phenomenon my school
and then the subordinate mine and the
only species we usually work with that
is solitary species is the hamster as
you may know so what happens in
captivity and social behavior actually
we need to know how the social bottom is
in order to respect it the various
species should be housed worked
forth and actually did social housing
it's supposed to be the best source of
enrichment given the proper amount of
spacing and the proper page dimension
and of course number of animals and if
they have enough resources because if
not it could generate competition and
fighting so there are some experimental
proceedings that that mean let's say
social it so peace of isolation sorry
when it's for short period like surgery
or some experimental procedures well it
can be let's say tolerate it but then it
when it is for longer periods it is
actually the main source of emotional
and social distress in various species
so we should be aware of this and there
are a lot of behavioral tasks that are
developed over these social interactions
for instance social defeats in which
should take him to town that is
stressful both for the intruder and for
the resident this is usually used with
mice they can be both stressed out about
this social interaction and we also
should be very aware that there can be
some social communication behind us
because they can communicate through
ultrasound vocalization and pheromone
same thing that we are we're best about
it and we cannot see what's going on and
they can warn each other about something
that is going on because they have alarm
vocalization and even alarm pheromones
what happens with agonistic behavior
that of course is very related to social
behavior and needed to to make the
social structure remain let's say so the
aggression or the threatening postures
that has to do with dominant and with
submission or usually there's some
posture of offensive aggression or
dominant as a threatening posture that
involves polar action hypothesis
sometimes persecution and broach
sometimes allegory meaning and as you
can see here in the picture in mind it's
very common the Barbarian but if they're
chewing of the before of the subordinate
in this case and there can be fighting
biting boxing and wallowing in a fight
with especially between male and the
defensive or submission posture that is
actually intended to have an attained
appeasement function it's usually a
lateral position or as fine position
exposing the
ventral abdomen as you can see in the
above picture with two legs fighting
when one of them it's applying the
dominant position on the other day
subordinate position so there are very
typical sequences first starting with
them the TMB balance posture trying to
maintain distance and even if the
animals I mean if the animal is
subordinate it can even breathe
to avoid and to appease the dominant
behavior or aggressive behavior if
possible their subordinate will try to
escape and if not the dominant will try
to attack or the subordinate will try to
defend itself so what happens with the
atomistic behavior in captivity as I
said before we should respect the
approbation pattern of the species base
15 species is precarious they should be
grouped house while if it's my for
instance that they are populated areas
we should see if we should group house
them or not regarding depending on
resources habituation to target page
mates number of animals the gauge size
etc and about week routine well actually
we should never regroup adult especially
if they're male if they were not raised
up together because they didn't fight
for us also we need to recognize those
postures of dominance and Submission and
in the case of life especially we should
recognize recognize this so-called
balilla effect that is they over alpha
blooming and the over barbering that
Ethan cause and assertive dermatitis
when it's excessive of course
okay about terrible territorial behavior
actually the communal or the group
territory makes protection finding food
and storing large amounts of food a lot
easier of course it depends on the
animal density and resources and the
main functions of territorial behavior
are social functions reproductive of
course for instance nesting behavior
residential but I think it's I haven't
missed out here sorry when there are low
activity periods the animals shall come
out they're in their territory and of
course they can use it to defend
themselves from predators for food
storage as I saw as I said before and
this territory is very well defended
usually by the dominant male of the
colony
with search for aggression to intruders
whether they are Kentucky Fitz or
Replicators well I I said this before
mice are very territorial
again untrue der and it is even used in
a behavior done so the territorial
behavior of the wild ancestors of our
laboratory animals if to gig or to
burrow underground galleries and tunnels
with caves with several several
entrances usually these entrances are
next to some stones or brushes or a
bunch of leads leads in order to
recognize if the territory and
to go back as if it were a benchmark for
them to recognize they of course they
also use on for typically use to mark
their territory with urine urine
I'm sorry and fake fecal marking and
also with sentence marking tool
pheromones welcomes have there's some
very specialized and developed sense of
recognition spatial orientation they use
the environment environmental cues and
special keys and benchmarks to recognize
their territory and they can form a
cognitive map about their own territory
this is very used for behavioral tasks
that are assessing special learning such
as mazes all kind of kind of methods are
based on these behavior what happens in
captivity on territorial behavior
actually due to a small cage size
usually the territorial behavior and
their kinetic behavior it's very little
expressed because they don't have enough
space to express it um
nevertheless we can increase this space
or the way of expression of territorial
behavior by environmental enrichment for
instance using tunnels or stairs or
ramps as you can see in the picture and
if they need more exercise because in
the wild their ancestors will avoid what
long distances to in order to find food
which doesn't happen in captivity so we
could enrich the environment and try to
make them make more exercise by
using our running wheels or different
levels in your gauges also we can use
loose material so that they can dig and
burrow and to express the nesting
behavior that is very important
important especially in mine and
exploratory behavior that is very
related of course to high behavior
it's very intense in rodents and
although this is a self motivated
behavior that is it has inner drive to
explore their environment it always
increases with novelty we put a new
stimulus so the exploration for the
environment artists main functions to
get containerized
with this environment to find me new
escape fluids from potatoes to search
for food and mate as well and rodents
have this distinctive knot or patterns
to explore they can either work run jump
climb dig and even know to explore their
their their answer their environment or
surrounding and they usually do it in
this typical segment of first
progressions then attention and they
stretch to smell a little bit further
and they continue to march to where they
were going and they use a wearing
posture as well to see what's farther
away this exploratory behavior is also
used as after a normal pattern to to
make some behavioral tasks that are
based on these exploratory behavior for
instance all kind of native so
happens in captivity with exploratory
behavior actually our animals live in a
very monotonous environment that if they
don't have any novelty or very little
new stimuli to get involved in
exploration so what can we do about it
well we can enrich the environment with
some novelty and with some complexity in
the environment it of course will induce
exploration we can use several objects
we can use well as you can see here in
the picture whether it's something you
buy and it's quite expensive or it's
something you normally if well flew away
in the garbage such as cardboard tubes
and boxes so any of these objects and
these um environmental enrichment device
it will increase exploration and an
enriched their complexity in their
environment but we should be aware that
excessive novelty it's also stressful
because it makes the environment very
difficult to predict very unpredictable
and that is also stressful so we should
balance penalty so that is not stressful
for the animals well social behavior
sexual behavior is ruled mostly with by
the pheromones as I said before
pheromones are very important for
communication between both and it's what
it's called same a chemical
communication because it's a chemical
way of communicate and it's involved in
courtship there are sexual attraction
pheromones and
well courtship actually involves also
ultrasonic calling for for mating but
also these pheromones are involving a
few special that say effects on behavior
sexual behavior and on and tonal
variations in their physiology of the
animals for instance their Bundaberg
effect that when there's a male present
it can accelerate the puberty onset on a
group of preppy girl female only due to
thermal something there's the labeled
effect that when no man is present the
group of female will have a regular
estrus cycle or even no cycle at all a
mobile cycling and on the country the
weeding effect explains how the
endurance and with the major you during
buildings I mentioned before will elicit
estrus in cycling female and this is
very used for synchronizing estrus this
is very very commonly used in animal
facilities to see when I opinion estrus
actually we should be aware of the
adverse effect that is when a different
male that was not the mate of Athena is
present during the first third of the
pregnancy they can be can be up to 50%
embryos option so we should be should
take care of this as well what happens
in captivity with sexual behavior well
actually all reproductive wayde's
depends on management it has been
not on on managers they're directed
mating is actually against their natural
preferences of animals it does not
respect nor hierarchy nor provinces
because there are preferences were
mating and even worse is in waiting
because it goes against the natural
preference that I'm not have for
unrelated major histocompatibility
complex I mean they try to mate with
animals that are not related to them and
in breeding with in exactly the opposite
so we should be aware of that of course
we used some of the attacked by total
before to synchronize estrus we'll use
it let's say you know benefit and that
can be made by using a little bit of
bedding that is that has some male urine
I'm putting it in the female cage
what about maternal behavior well burp
as you may know is usually nocturnal so
it's very difficult to see and first
take pictures of that's why this one
very difficult still that that female
mounted it but and parenting it's very
complex behavior pattern it's actually
prepared a bit is communal among the
various species such as rats and it also
can be coming on and on life this along
nursing exceeds and it's it's very
typical and we can even use it for
benefit if we have some orphan Cubs that
means that a female will nurse
perhaps there are not of her own but
were birth and
they're from another demon also the
parenting behavior includes leaking of
the pups given them physical protection
recovering and transporting the pups
through this scruffing behavior that you
can see in the pictures and of course in
order to nurse their folks the female
will adopt adopt there's some lactating
posture you know lying with exposing her
her belly in order that the pups can
nurse and milk so what happens in
captivity and with maternal behavior
actually all management problems can
affect pop survival rate Oh
so again it bends enough like that
because all sources of stress like for
instance noise smell and others
overpopulation they can lead to maternal
behavioral disorders such as publicly
act or maternal and different if lack of
maternal care and nursing and proper
nursing so um
actually it is it is very rare to see
pup killing and cannibalism even though
it is reported what usually happens it
does is that parts can die because of
bad mothering or a lack of maternal care
and then there's the normal scavenging
behavior that is part of the feeding
behavior befitting boundaries
absolutely normal in rodents so actually
it's not that common say cannibalism but
to see a female fitting with the pub
corpse but probably she didn't directly
killed it well what I wanted to tell you
that also excessive maternal care
excessive leaking can be bad for the
pups I mean it can even well maybe not
kill them but it can injure them by an
excessive licking
so probably signal drivers will agree
that excessive maternal care is also bad
for the pups okay and now to smart as
I've said before we need to know and
understand what normal behavioral
patterns are involved in order to
respect it
and to ensure animal welfare it is very
important to understand about the
program and to study it because it will
help us to us as well for in animals as
I said before as a salient viable that
we all tell us about internal processing
very complex processing that it happened
underneath and about emotional states
those animals we are sorry and if we
want to ensure the freedom to express
normal behavior of items we need to know
them if not even obvious be able to
respect them and also if we know how
normal behavior is involved and you will
be able to select the proper animal
model for I know some that we need to do
or for menial illness we want to model
we will be able then to decide which
species to use which strain and if
there's a behavioral disorder in that
animal as a model of a human behavior
disorder we need to be able to recognize
normal from abnormal or from illness or
from a disorder also if you know how
normal behavior is we will be able to
select the proper or the best behavioral
task we should use for that model twenty
times for numerous idea psychiatric
disorder and as I said we need to know
the normal behaviors in order to know
how to assess them and how to measure
them because they do not necessary going
to be measured the same way and as I had
said at the beginning of my talk
we need to recognize their alter
behavior from the normal one and for
that we need to know how the Norma leaf
so finally I'd like to recommend you a
few reading material that you can find
well even in there's a website that you
can see and several papers and a book
you can consider reading if you want to
explore live a little bit more about
normal behavior and with this I would
like to thank you all for your attention
thank you very much for being there last
year and well I'm willing to hear some
questions from you so I'm giving bad
control to more so well Thank You marina
for such a great and informative
presentation wow so much that I can
apply to my program I know I'm gonna be
calling you in the future for help and
so impressive but before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to remind our audience and
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can then
so our first question is going to be
from Shelly
garmisch ID from University of Manitoba
how do you manage stereotype ease type
ease such as a circling of one Mouse
amongst its cage mates in your facility
Marina and okay so CEO type it um let me
see if I'm an area
first of all surfing behavior can be a
behavioral stereotype of course but also
you should further ourselves if there's
not any physical illness that can
express circling behaviors well for
instance an inner ear illness when you
rule that out if it's mainly a
behavioral problem and it's only
displayed by one Mouse in a cage you can
use some environmental enrichment in
that cage if you didn't have any because
usually we hear some stereotypical
stereotypic behavior it's very dependent
on the environment conditions so you can
try that
hmm you say here one Mouse a month is
its cage mate I'm not sure I understand
your question about that because certain
behavior is usually something that it's
a self-directed behavior it is not
directed to the other minds of the cage
if you mean a mouse is circling around
another one that can be the start of
fight so you should be aware of that and
maybe think about separate that may help
for instance from the others
let's get back to Marcel okay thank you
very much and by the way for the
individual there's a comment here that
marina don't be concerned about your
English it is perfect Brent thank you
for the comment okay this question is
from Robert come from the Food and Drug
Administration and why sounds and
vibrations why not well not ideal would
you think they adapt to them over time
relatively quickly the same for smells
okay it is true that it they can adapt
and adjust to those noises even if there
are ultrasonic one the thing I'm
concerned of is about you let's say
sounds or smells that they are not
funnier with we can imagine that that
they will arbitrate eventually to a
sound of an equipment but the thing is
we don't hear the ultrasonic sounds that
that device might be generating and
ultrasonic sounds can interfere with
their communication that is why I think
it's a main concern too well it can be
measured with for the proper divisor so
we can see if I don't know what computer
for instance has if I'm generating a lot
of auto sonic sound so we might think of
I don't know putting some somewhere else
or farther away from the cages
okay the next question comes from our
hero's car Rio duckie from the
experimental research center elfin
pharmaceutical company how would you
deal with finding in a cage of rats
isolate the one who is dominant
Oh Pierre I'm sorry okay done so the
question was how do I deal with fighting
words I shouldn't
uhm isolate the dominant one
because actually isolation it's also
harmful for social species for a
gregarious species as well but what you
can do is first to ourselves if there's
only one rat fighting with all the
others because it doesn't always look
like that I mean sometimes they all
fight with each other in that case you
should try to see if there's a way to
enlarge their page or to enrich their
cage with some environmental enrichment
that they can all use as a social
management for instance it arrived tubes
or a cardboard box where one of them can
hide for instance there's coordinate can
hide you can separate some rods that are
fighting but you won't want to isolate
them I mean to cause them a single house
them so you can separate them in a node
two and two or two and three well
depending on how many are they I hope I
answered your question
Thank You marina the next question comes
from Saskia aren't from Utrecht
University could you please provide us
with references regarding your
statements regarding for example the
effects of what you call social
isolation and regarding the social
organization or the different species
okay
well social isolation would be to be
single house for our special studies
strictly food areas there are some
behavioral tasks based on social
isolation that use the isolation as a
source of social strength that is the
most typical so harmful source of
strength in the various animals such as
human human being actually so that
that's why I mean with social isolation
to have straightly gregarious animal
housed by itself without cage mange
thank you again marina
the next question comes from Damian
O'Donoghue from prospect solutions will
breed Sprague Dawley rats in trails from
time to time we need to interrupt
breeding for a week or two because of
holiday periods we usually remove the
stud mails and house them alone for the
duration will it be better to houses
that males in pairs or small groups
rather than a thousand alone during
these breaks
okay this is a very interesting question
if they were I mean if they the original
cage was one male and two or three
female you shouldn't cage put in a cage
all the male we breeders together even
in pairs because they will definitely
fight especially because there are
breeders so there they have this they
are empowered to reproduce to me so
there they will probably fight against
each other because the the social order
but what you can do is you can single
house them but next to the female age
well it depends on the type of cage but
in order to allow them to see each other
and if possible to smell each other and
even if you have wire cages to touch
each other they say that would be
something to recommend and if not if you
have some milk wheat breeders that are
very a group house together and where
were braced up together from stuff they
are siblings then you can regroup them
together in these breaks because they
are used to each other they are used to
the other cage mate but never we group
males special readers that weren't used
to each other's company because they
they will fight definitely nice question
from Teresa mckernon from animal care
systems recently we have been taught to
transfer nesting material from the old
cage to the new cage as there is
aggression inhibiting urine order kills
in the nest and not to transfer all
bedding because it has aggression
inducing urine cues can you please
discuss okay it's true that transferring
the let the tape reviews nesting
material or bedding material comes with
a your intern team of the that's a
previous Kate
it's actually the same cage so it
carries all the during sending and
Martine of the cage mates so it means
that not only this aggression in
inhibition sent but also with each
hierarchy order has each of the cage
mates that is why it's viable to do this
transferring the old material today to
the new bedding or to transfer the
nesting material so in order to keep the
social hierarchy of the social order
quiet and without messing with it
because when when animals know which is
their their hierarchy and status or the
social order status they do not need to
fight but if they don't know because the
cell marking is lost they will that they
fight again to offend in their social
order that is why using the old bedding
or nesting material is help
okay the next question comes from
Elizabeth felony phalanges from the
United States Geological Survey national
wildlife health center how can we know
what is the right balance of enough
novelty and not too much to be stressful
what cues might we use to decide that
our enrichment program has the ideal
level of novelty okay this is a great
question and it's very difficult to
answer either but well one cue you can
use it is in an environment
environmental enrichment program you
need to set up how often and which type
of enrichment material are you going to
use an to exchange if the animals are
explore exploring the the new object
let's say it means it's still a novelty
when they stop exploring it it's because
they are habituated to it that's why
when you want to change it to renew it
and they have stopped exploring it
because it's not new anymore so if there
are still exploring their surroundings
from the objects and chewing them around
and you know climbing into them depends
on the objects of course then do not
change them because there is still a
grade latrine novelty stimula similar
and if you change it too soon then it
can generate an unpredictable
environment the next
from Cory Abbot from Tech Mira the
question is a little bit difficult for
me to understand but they see marina if
you can respond to this I'm gonna read
exactly how the question is asked lead
boot effect mail in the room different
cage can cause this effect okay um it
depends on how far this cage here in the
room but if it let's say if it's near
enough so that the other I mean the
female can smell them the army near the
mail it can cause this liquid effect as
well actually many times this is used a
way of trying to synchronize that the
estrus or female just by putting the
mail in the same room it depends on the
size of the room and where the mail
cages regarding the female cages it fits
near enough so so they can smell each
other or what smell is the most
important thing here and remember that
pheromones are volatile compounds and
all right so they it can travel in the
air even if we don't notice it so
sometimes just being in the next shell
in the net so it's enough to produce
this effect next question is from Maria
Andres from cellular and molecular
biology I try to enrich with paper towel
rolls but the rats eat them very fast is
that okay or shall we avoid given them
these kinds of toys
okay actually chewing and knowing if a
sort of exploratory behavior as well but
you don't want them to eat the material
because it can be harmful currently it's
not harmful because probably paper
towels will not be harmful for rat but
well it won't last very long in inner
gated so you should try with a thicker
paper for instance not towel paper any
other cardboard that they will chew and
eventually they will probably eat little
pieces but it will last longer you can
use these um person disposable cups as a
way of enrichment and nesting material
they will to it as well but probably it
will last longer
okay let's do one more and then we're
gonna have to wrap it off and know that
there are other questions but I think
we're running out of time so say for
Maria undress also the question is shall
we keep adult male and female rats
separated but in contiguous cages well
this is very similar as I said before
yes if you want the female to be cycling
and to elicit the estrus yes and but
make sure that there are not only
contiguous but they can smell each other
see each other and even touch each other
if you want this is a way of avoiding
them to mate if you don't want to but
there are close enough to smell each
other's problems
so all those effect I told you will take
place well unfortunately we're out of
time I want to thank the audience for
their interesting questions and
participation in today's event and of
course marina very well done
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 2015
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event so see you next time and good
bye